日本語アドバイス
第10回何時までおはよう」って言えます
かいい質問だ
他人の視線どこまで気にするやっと観光客
が普通に日本に来れるようになりましたね
観光客が一気に来て日常
生活で何か変わると思い変わると思います
かアメリカ人
うるせえなという発言が多分多くなると
思う少なくとも僕は確実にそうなる粗大
ゴミの適切な処分方法を教えてください
リサイクルショップに持っていくべき
細かく
切って少しずつ捨てるべきそれとも普通に
お金を出して市に処分してもらうべき
後輩に
押し付けるべき天空操作欲しいってこの前
言ってたよねいや僕はテーブルがならば
座るものいるねあ
うん高級寿司レストランで
わさび抜きでという発言を忘れて
自分が平気を装う時の
表情を教えてください
全然大丈夫です
むしろ好きです
道元さんは日本人から
変なアドバイス
受けたことありますか
自分日本人の友達から早口言葉を教えて
もらったが教えてもらいましたが今度
僕がそれを言おうとしたら
笑われましたその人日本人だよね
変なアドバイスじゃないんだけどよくその
アクセントのことで
例えばね
僕が間違えて
様のことを
夏って言ってしまったら多分日本人の
ほとんどはそれを聞いてあっ上下それ
間違ってる
夏じゃなくて
夏と言ってくれると思うんだけどそれだけ
だったら
正解がまだわからないというのは
夏がなのか夏場なのか
そこまで言わないとわかんないからまあ
その正解何っていう感じなんだよね
外国人向けにそのアクセントのことを教え
ている時は助詞
助詞まで言ってくださいね女子じゃなくて
でまあ日本人こういうのをどう教えたら
いいかわかんないからこそ僕そのペイ
チェアのシリーズを作ったんだけど夏シー
もスコア打ちやまだから
要するに
教わってないことはなかなか教えられな
いっていうか
学んでないことはなかなか教えられない
女子
女子女子アイメッセージを日本語で何と
言いますかそうだな
言い方はたくさん
松本潤さん
えっマジでコメントありがとうあ
ごくせい見ましたカタカナの言葉早く読め
ませんどうしたらいいと思いますか
未だに自分の名前のカタカナをこう頻繁に
忘れてしまう人に聞かない方がいいと思う
んだけどいずれ日本語の名詞のほとんどが
カタカナ外来語になっちゃうからまあ自然
と
早く読めるようになると思うんだよね
外来語しか使われていないアニメ早く見
たいね
見たくないの自動詞と
他動詞を覚えるのって大変ですよね私に
気づいてください
先輩いや気づいたけど
質問は何
漢字の読み書きを両方できるようになり
たいですがどうしたらいいと思いますか
授業です既にたくさん勉強していますが
半分ぐらいは
忘れていますいいお知らせがある
漢字を書かなきゃいけないっていう時って
もう日本語の授業を
受けている時だけなんだよね漢字を書ける
ようになりたいという夢を捨てて
代わりにサイバーパンクエッジラナーズを
見て日本語のスラングを学ぼうほとんどの
言語もそうだと思うけど日本語で日本語で
会話をしているとき
相手の言っていることはわかりますが
なかなか自分の伝えたいことが
伝えられない何かアドバイスありますか
これはね
第2言語の話
だけじゃないんだよね自分の母語だって
こう
頭のいい人の説明についてきてもその人と
同じようにこう物事を流暢に綺麗にこう
説明できるとは限らないんだよねだから
まあ特に
欧米と
西洋の哲学の違いについてのお話とか
ごめん大学時代に自分がバカだと悟った時
の話だ
質問なんだっけ日本語の文法の中で一番
苦労したものはどれですか一番苦労したの
は何ですか物だって使い方たくさんある
もん強いて言うならどっちがいい
アクセントと雰囲気は完璧だけど
語彙力と
文法はひどいそれとも
単語はたくさんしていて
文法は完璧だけど
発音は最低そうだな俺なら全社かな何しろ
その
前者かな俺ならそうだなといってもそこ
までバカっぽい印象は
与えないかな
けどよたくさんの方言を混ぜて話したら
日本人は違和感を覚えると思いますか
例えば
標準語を使っている時に
急に関西弁に変わったら変だと思われます
かいやです
というのはこれも
他人の視線どこまで気にするかによると
思うんだけどまあ正直
言って
賢く思われたいのであればまあある程度ね
日本語のアクセントと
発音を
勉強して
標準を
極めた方が一番
無難だと思うんだよねただし
上手って言われたいのであれば